pour moi c'était un jeu et un
entomologiste amateur je me suis dit 'il
est temps que justice soit faite et j'ai
voulu te construire un temps un monument
spécialement érigé pour eux c'est la
définition même donné un sac à riom où
mon but était d'enlever la part aux
jeunes arbitres qui paralyse le monde
s'y met nullement et beaucoup de femmes
qui n'avaient pas l'entraîneur italien
de patients peuvent devraient pas à moi
de faire le jeu de go ce légal
talentueux jeunes mamans elles vivent un
an a pour cadre un petit bébé par année
mais pour tout cas va donner sa vie pour
sauver un seul de ces petits bébés
encore je les présente comme ça ça leur
enlève là bas la finlande à l'heure mais
les ont fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
ils ont quitté 7 1 qui les menace et
qu'ils étaient noyés depuis des années
tu vois georges brossard celui qui a
contribué à faire connaître les insectes
au québec et peut-être nous l'y faire
aimer un peu est décédé d'un cancer ce
matin à l'âge de 79 ans
il a été très populaire il a fourni
l'insectarium de montréal puis ceux de
la nouvelle orléans de terre-neuve et de
shanghai
l'automobiliste jean-pierre bourassa est
un ami un ancien collègue monsieur
bourassa avec monsieur brossât et
l'expert de montréal puis à bord ont été
parmi ceux qui ont participé à la
création de l'insectarium avec georges
brossard donc on retrouve dans nos
studios à trois rivières monsieur
bourassa bonsoir bonsoir ce bovin avait
été premier directeur de l'insectarium
donc vous avez travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec georges brossard
parce que les gens savent pas mais
jusqu'à la fin de la trentaine georges
brossard était notaire alors comment on
passe d'être notaire à co fondateur de
l'insectarium à écouter mois est morte
téléphoner au milieu des années 80 mais
au mieux les années 80 je faisais des
recherches sur les insectes en versus
québec à trois-rivières et georges était
intéressé à ce que à ce que je faisais
alors
il m'a appelé il m'a invité à le
rencontrer à quelques occasions pour
discuter des insectes comme tel parce
qu'il voulait vraiment vraiment tout
connaître sur les insectes et il voulait
diffuser ses connaissances au grand
public
alors c'est là que il m'a invité à
siéger avec monsieur bourque pierre
bourque
on a fait ça pendant deux ans trois ans
pour discuter comme telle de son fameux
temple aux intel et voulait absolument
diffusés au grand public
ces notions ses connaissances sur les
insectes et il voulait vraiment
connaître le tous y avait sur les haies
est ce que vous savez d'où sa part où ça
sans faire de mauvais jeux mans où il a
eu la piqûre
bon je jase brossard ont vécu dans un
milieu plus disons plutôt en fête
agricole la salle jeunesse comme tel un
milieu dense est plus ouvert qu'un
milieu citadin et il est il était en
contact avec la nature comme tel et lui
m'a déjà dit que il avait émis en fait
voir ce qu'il voyait dans les champs
notamment des grillons institut est une
ville a raconté une anecdote dans une
entrevue weeds m
on va me donner on est allé dans une
cuve à eau - et mes parents pour
chercher de l'eau pour les animaux oui
mais il y avait des abeilles étaient en
train de se noyer ce que vous a raconté
tout à fait oui piqué il connaît ça
disons que et il voyait ses abeilles
mûri et ça lui faisait que ça ils
faisaient mal alors à ce moment-là il a
voulu en connaître davantage savoir
pourquoi les abeilles s'y retrouvaient
se retrouvèrent c'est un droit lors et
il a commencé en fait vraiment comme ça
en contact avec une nature beaucoup plus
comment gérer ça chante est que urbain
ils ont visé sa part et qu'il avait mis
sa main dans l'aube et liza weil avait
monté sur sa même il n'avait pas piqué
puis là il s'était dit elle mais elle me
rende elle me respecte parce que je les
ai sauvé et donc les animaux et les
insectes finalement sont pas si méchants
hawks exactement les sens mais avec doc
qui répétait souvent aussi lors de
conférences à des jeunes
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de l'entendre à
plusieurs reprises donné des conférences
à tu es jeune et c'était souvent avec
des anecdotes semblables qui la
portaient surtout pour dire aux gens que
les insectes n'était pas dangereux quand
il tentait aussi de connaître le
pourquoi de l'existence d'une si grande
diversité d'insectes sur la planète et
ça ça l'a toujours fasciné parce qu'on
dérange et au delà d'un million
d'espèces d'insectes différents
différentes qu'on doit identifier
alors ça ça l'a toujours fasciné et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il l'a
fait plusieurs expéditions dans les
jungles soit au costa rica soit en fait
du côté de l'asie ou de l'afrique comme
tel donc il était très curieux il était
7h boulimique cela voulait il leur
prenait toujours plus oui absolument
et c'était aussi une très bonne personne
en ce sens qu'il voulait partager avec
des jeunes ce qu'ils connaissaient sur
les insectes par le par les nobel
parce que vous parlez des expéditions
mais il a fait aussi beaucoup de
d'expédition sur les plateaux télévision
on l'a vu dans un light show aux états
unis notamment la présence de
personnages aussi en même temps un
espèce dean diana jones d un siècle
est ce que c'était un personnage c'est
vraiment lui il était aussi énergique
que ça aussi passionné que ça tous les
jours pour être passionné
oui ils avaient de l'énergie aussi pour
le faire et c'est quelqu'un que jamais
cherché à être la vedette comme tel et
ils se sentent elle a oublié les
vedettes
avant c'était les insectes les oui
absolument les insectes
il voulait partager ses connaissances
avec le commun des mortels et surtout
rendre ces insectes accessibles lors de
l'observation
lorsqu'on les découvre dans la nature
pourquoi ils sont là et tout ça ça a été
un bonhomme qui a été fasciné par ce
monde
parlez-nous de l'inspiration qu'il a été
pour le film le papillon bleu qui
raconte l'histoire de deux jeunes
enfants qui souffre d'un cancer
oui tout à fait et ce genre je suis bien
au courant de ce qui est arrivé en
premier on met en mode ont mentionné en
fait l'existence de ce jeune qui voulait
en fait absolument avoir un téléphone
jazz brossard pour aller visiter ses
collections nationales
ça c'était un rêve d'enfant oui c'est un
rêve d'enfant et je les mentionnaient à
georges brossard et immédiatement il a
contacté le jeune et le jeune visiter
des collections d'insectes et tout ça il
a découvert avec lui au costa rica le
fameux papillon 2 d'où le film par la
suite qu'ils étaient tirés de cette
aventure comme tel alors vous voyez
c'est un bonhomme qui était vraiment
fasciné mais aussi très bon au niveau
humanitaire
il voulait à faire partager avec les
jeunes ses connaissances sur ce monde à
découvrir quels souvenirs gardez vous je
garde un souvenir de lui comme un
bonhomme qui étaient complémentaires aux
scientifiques
vous savez les scientifiques constante
événements de communiquer le plus
possible on le fait dans un cercle
scientifique généralement mais georges
m'ont inspiré personnellement aussi pour
communiquer avec les gens dans les
écoles dès lors de conférences et
ensuite dans l'écriture de bouquets tout
ça et vous savez georges brossard au
fait deux préface d'un de 2010 sur les
inserts et à chaque fois il mentionne
son souci de faire connaître au grand
public le monde des insectes
à chaque fois c'était un petit peu son
discours comme tel vous le scientifique
lui le vulgarisateur
comment comment on pourrait lui rendre
hommage en quelques mots moi moi je
pense que je dois ça devrait faire
partie
ddd documentaire comme tel qu'on fait
dans le monde
nommé l'insectarium le centre georges
brassens ça pourrait aller jusqu'à
l'europe sous la main et au moins faire
ta voire peut-être son territoire où il
vivait peut-être un site en fait georges
brossard aussi mais je pense que
l'insectarium va certainement lui
rendent hommage et moi personnellement
je vais le contacter et l'insectarium à
ce sujet soyez en certains merci
monsieur bourassa
merci pour cet hommage ce soir ça me
fait plaisir merci monsieur une soirée à
deux mois